the Joe Rogan experience I don't have
the discipline yeah his sit in class
listen I was too [ __ ] I wasn't
interested so crazy that you can't sit
in class and listen and yet you can do
the double header three-hour podcast
that's not hard we're talking about cool
[ __ ] you're a cool guy you're fun to
talk to
it's our it's it's the way the material
is delivered huh and the last one was
you know what you'll see but it's way
more these two guys talking than me no
I'm mostly moderated and mostly wound up
agreeing with the guy who made the game
changers documentary mostly with what he
was saying in terms of science in terms
of whether or not it's healthy to eat a
hundred percent vegan diet according to
everything he's showing me it is yeah
according to everything he was showing
me and he had as much science as you
could no no it's just a matter of doing
it properly
absolutely Kevin Smith on your show I've
considered trying to do like a vegan
month or a vegan week or something I
haven't gone through with it yet but I'm
probably gonna I think it's different
for different people too I really do I
think some people have real issues with
it some people have gotten off the vegan
diet and they've they've quit and they'd
like a seat a little less me really well
I mean it's really I think it's
different for everybody to men I think
some people could do it with no problems
and I think other people struggle more
and I don't know why I'm not a
nutritionist but I know that a lot of
people that wind up trying it out
eventually give up
it's like 84% I know a couple story
goons yeah but I know I don't have like
a moral judgement for it or anything I
just feel like maybe it's something
worth trying because I eat a lot of meat
yeah and I'm trying to get I have you
know if I wrote a business plan for my
new place as you do when you have a new
business and the first thing on the
business plan is buy my 40th birthday I
want to be the healthiest I've ever been
well I don't think cutting meat out is
the move see this is what I think about
all this like I think you could
definitely be healthy and be a vegan
according to everything this guy was
showing me everything James Wilkes was
showing I don't really want to be a
vegan but I like me have no moral qualms
with it and I like how it tastes
give me good but I thought maybe if I
did a little bit I can at least try
it makes a difference no I think the
real thing to do is omnivorous diets and
I think this is one of the things that
we prove today in this conversation
between Chris Kresser and James Wilkes
is that the omnivorous diet is like a
natural healthy thing you can do a vegan
diet though you can do it right
according to everything he was showing
me today and I believe this - if you're
just doing it correctly if you monitor
your nutrient levels you take you know
vitamin b12 supplements just something
he advocates I was like that makes sense
to me but I don't believe that means bad
for you I think that sedentary lifestyle
shitty foods yeah and eating meat since
the beginning of time yeah yeah this is
how we became people literally one of
the primary theories for why the human
brain got so big so quick you had more
access to protein because we're cooking
things with fire and we learned how to
hunt better because we our brains kept
growing as we're just figuring out the
throwing arm they think is a possible
factor like somehow another the ability
to throw something at something and kill
it like made us money can kill some
farther away that's a gale it's caves
yeah bro we're so weak all compared to
like animals yeah yeah an animal would
[ __ ] us up so any any even a small ish
animal yeah [ __ ] aside Sierra will kick
your [ __ ] here just kicking ass oh
god yeah yeah I get it we need we need
we need to leave some help need some
weapons I would about we were like
though let me imagine going back and
seeing what a person was like when we
started becoming people how [ __ ]
freaky would that be like see like see
everything oh my god just real scared
but like what would it be like to just
hang out a tribe of Neanderthals and see
what they were likely a different kind
of person yeah I wonder if it would be I
mean like mentally freeing you're
singularly focused on food and shelter
and not you know I don't know if you
have the your you know you know a lot of
like the [ __ ] worries that we have
but so it could be awful simple but at
the same time the constant fear of
starving and freezing to death
that would be [ __ ] all that's bad we're
gonna get there dude Arletta end up in
Waterworld pretty
[Applause]